(funky music)
- We all started.
I mean, just specifically,
Hannibal, Arturo and us.
None of us had any experience,
we didn't have
like TV experience.
We're working on Broad City all
year but Hannibal and Arturo
are going an acting
on different things,
and I really felt their
experience come back
to the set and feed the set.
- It's good to see everybody,
it's good to see just how
they've grown as actors, as
businesswomen, as creators.
They've both directed
episodes now,
it's been great to
see the progression.
- Jamie, be strong,
penis, be weak, be weak
- They're so talented
both of them, in their own
individual ways
and I hope that we
keep writing to their strengths
but their strengths
keep expanding
and I feel like I
learned more about
how good they were
from directing them.
- Okay, so we have
to talk about this
whole relationship thing
- What
- Think about what we have
sacrificed to enter this
sexless fart party.
- People get emotionally
invested with characters
I've done it before
with a television show
when somebody break
up, you're like,
they broke up, I
can't believe it
I want them to get back together
Hello my dear
- [Ilana] Hello my
um, my fluid dude
- [Hannibal] They never really
doubted that I would be back
and that I didn't, but I
think the fans really thought
I was off the show.
- He's my boyfriend
- I'm having sex with a
girl, afterwards she's like,
so you know if you're
going to be back?
Hey, this isn't the time
for that first of all,
this is not what we're here for.
This is not a meet and greet.
This is not an interview.
I don't want to talk
storylines with you right now
I just met you four hours ago.
(funky music)